there are quite a few reasons why you
should be consuming two to four eggs
every single day
now the egg is really considered
a perfect food not just a perfect
protein it's low carb
it's higher fat and it's high quality
moderate protein out of all the proteins
i'm talking about beef chicken fish
lamb
pork all these other proteins are muscle
protein an egg is a completely different
type of protein it's the most
bioavailable of all proteins the most
efficient protein when you're digesting
it getting the least amount of waste
which then turns into glucose so out of
all the different proteins you can eat
definitely eggs rank number one not to
mention eggs have a complete profile of
essential amino acids so today i'm going
to talk about the benefits of egg but
primarily for your skin
and your hair i'm also going to cover
some data on whether you should eat raw
eggs or cooked eggs i'll talk about
allergies
and a couple other points so let's start
from the top now the protein in egg
believe it or not is not just in the egg
white it's also in an egg yolk in fact
there's more protein in the yolk okay
than there is white if you actually do a
comparison of equal value as far as
weight goes so if you're just eating egg
whites you're missing out not only on
additional protein but a lot of other
nutrients but the egg yolk is
super concentrated in fat soluble
vitamins which really support the skin
and especially your hair so it's really
difficult to find foods that have the
active form of vitamin a retinol but egg
yolk is at the top of the list and
vitamin a is really important in skin
health if you're deficient your skin is
going to be rough and dry vitamin a is
also very important for your eyes as
well as your sinuses and the immune
system and many other additional things
now one point about vitamin a that's
interesting
in the definitions of vitamin a
they include beta-carotene which is a
precursor of vitamin a to be vitamin a
when in fact it's really a precursor
it's not retinol so when you do your
analysis on nutritional density in foods
a lot of times you'll see like in kale
or spinach there's all this vitamin a
but it's actually the precursor beta
carotene so when we're talking about all
the benefits of vitamin a we're talking
about the bioavailable form retinol not
beta carotene now vitamin d is also in
eggs and
out of all the vitamins vitamin d is
right at the top of the list as far as
the importance for the skin if you're
deficient in vitamin d you can have
everything from
rashes to sun sensitivity to sun spots
to psoriasis all sorts of problems occur
in the skin if you're deficient in
vitamin d and also you'll have more
inflammation and more acne and as far as
vitamin d and foods in general it's not
very easy to find vitamin d foods but
eggs are one of the food that actually
contains vitamin d all right vitamin e
is that important for your skin
you better believe it it protects the
skin against uv radiation it helps break
down scarring it acts as a powerful
antioxidant for the skin as well as
internally as well then we have vitamin
k1 and vitamin k2
eggs are loaded with choline which is a
nutrient that prevents
a fatty liver from occurring it also is
essential for brain and nerve health
which includes keeping your mood high
and also improving your memory eggs also
contain a good amount of omega-3 fatty
acids another great thing for your skin
as well as a good
anti-inflammatory eggs also are loaded
with lesser than the antidote to
cholesterol so if you're concerned about
cholesterol eating eggs you don't have
to be concerned
eggs will increase your hdl and if
there's any extra cholesterol in your
body lecithin will will help counter
that excess cholesterol choline as well
eggs are loaded with b vitamins okay
especially b2
b3
b12
and biotin which is good for the hair
now since we're on the topic of biotin i
should go right to this right here raw
eggs what's my thought about eating raw
eggs now here's the thing in the egg
yolk
there is this compound called avidin and
avidin binds with biotin making it
unavailable for you to absorb okay so if
you consume
a lot of eggs over a long period of time
you'll probably become deficient in
biotin and that can affect your hair but
you would have to consume a lot of raw
eggs over a long period of time the
other point i want to make about raw
eggs is there's
enzyme inhibitors okay so potentially it
could inhibit the digestion of proteins
i think a little bit of raw eggs would
be fine but i wouldn't do a large amount
over a long period of time now what
about the point of getting salmonella in
raw eggs
well the odds of you getting salmonella
are one in thirty thousand you'd have to
consume five eggs a day for about 15
years
before there's a chance of getting
salmonella salmonella comes from sick
chickens chickens that have an altered
microbiome
but if you're consuming the eggs that i
recommend which are not commercial eggs
okay i'm recommending
pasture raised organic eggs the chance
of you getting salmonella are much much
less than winning
the virginia lottery okay so now i also
run into this this word pasteurized okay
you have pasteurized and pastured okay
two different
words here they do sometimes have
pasteurized eggs at the grocery store
okay
now what does that mean
well since there might be a chance of
getting some microbial infection on the
surface of the egg okay the shell like
salmonella they pasteurize the egg they
heat it up to a certain degree not to
cook the inside of the egg
but just to heat up the outside to
sterilize the eggs so when you see
pasteurized eggs that's really what's
occurring now when you have pastured
eggs we're talking about chickens that
roam around on different pastures being
able to eat
bugs and worms and grass this is the
type of egg that you want now when
someone has an allergy to egg it's to
the egg white okay not the yolk so if
you do have
an egg allergy what you could do
is just eat the yolks okay that way you
can get some protein you also can get
the benefit of all these things i'm
talking about right here another point
that people bring up when they talk
about raw eggs is that
they don't want to cook the egg because
they don't want oxidized cholesterol
well you're not going to get oxidized
cholesterol if you even scramble an egg
you would get oxidized cholesterol if
you were to
take this egg and put it through a high
pressure
device through small little particles
okay that's how you're going to get
oxidized cholesterol there is a good
amount of minerals in eggs there's
potassium there's magnesium there's also
iodine another very important
trace mineral that is not in a lot of
foods
but
it's in eggs
and selenium which is very important for
your thyroid in converting t4 to t3 the
other cool thing that's in eggs is these
carotenoids carotenoids include hundreds
of different compounds
these are two powerhouses lutein and
zeaxanthin okay so both of these
carotenoids
greatly support the skin because their
antioxidants as well as the eye
protecting you against
macular degeneration
cataracts and skin damage from the sun
and the bioavailability of these
carotenoids in eggs are much better than
in vegetables now i have a lot of
interesting videos and eggs and if you
haven't seen
this video it's fascinating check it out
i put it up right here
you